Où sont les robots?
On nous dit depuis 40 ans qu'ils arrivent bientôt.
Que bientôt ils feront tout pour nous:
la cuisine, le nettoyage, les achats, les courses, la construction. Mais ils ne sont pas là.
A la place, nos avons des immigrés qui font toutes ces tâches,
mais pas de robots.
Que pouvons-nous y faire? Que pouvons-nous dire?
Je veux vous laisser entrevoir une perspective différente,
un point de vue différent sur ces choses.
Voici une radio
d'un vrai scarabée, et d'une montre suisse, qui date de 1988. Regardez --
ce qui était vrai alors l'est toujours aujourd'hui.
Nous savons toujours créer les pièces, les bonnes pièces,
le circuit pour obtenir la puissance de calcul nécessaire,
mais nous ne savons pas les combiner pour créer quelque chose
qui fonctionnera réellement et sera aussi adaptif que ces systèmes.
Essayons donc d'observer sous une autre perspective.
Appelons le meilleur architecte, le plus grand architecte de tous les temps :
regardons ce que l'évolution peut faire pour nous.
Donc nous nous sommes lancés, nous avons créé une soupe primaire
avec beaucoup de morceaux de robots : des barres, des moteurs, des neurones.
on les a assemblés, et soumis à une sorte de sélection naturelle,
à une mutation, et récompensé les choses selon leur capacité à avancer.
Un travail très simple, mais il est intéressant de voir ce qui en est sorti.
Observez : vous pouvez voir plein de machines différentes
émerger. Elles se déplacent toutes,
elles bougent de plein de façons, et vous pouvez voir à droite,
que nous en avons créé un certain nombre,
qui fonctionnent vraiment. Ce ne sont pas des robots extraordinaires,
mais ils évoluent pour faire ce pour quoi nous les récompensons :
pour avancer. Tout cela a été fait sur ordinateur,
mais on peut aussi le faire dans le monde réel.
Voici un vrai robot à qui nous avons en fait
donné un ensemble de cerveaux,
qui s'affrontent, ou évoluent, sur la machine.
C'est comme un rodéo, ils sont tous sur la machine,
et ils sont récompensés selon leur vitesse ou leur capacité
à faire évoluer la machine.
Vous voyez que ces robots ne sont pas prêts
à dominer le monde, mais
ils apprennent peu à peu comment évoluer,
et ce, de manière autonome.
Dans ces deux exemples, nous avons simplement
des machines qui ont appris à marcher en laboratoire,
mais aussi des machines qui ont appris à marcher dans le monde réel.
Je veux vous montrer une autre approche,
ce robot, là-bas, qui a quatre jambes,
huit moteurs, quatre sur les genoux et quatre sur les hanches.
Il a aussi deux capteurs de verticalité qui lui disent
comment il est incliné.
Mais cette machine ne sait pas à quoi elle ressemble.
Vous la regardez et vous voyez ses quatre jambes,
la machine ne sait pas si c'est un serpent, un arbre,
elle n'a aucune idée de ce à quoi elle ressemble,
mais elle va essayer de le deviner.
Au début, elle fait des mouvements au hasard,
et elle essaye de deviner à quoi elle peut ressembler --
vous voyez un tas de choses lui traverser l'esprit,
un tas de modèles qui essayent d'expliquer le lien
entre la mise en action et la perception -- et puis elle essaie de
faire un second mouvement qui crée le plus grand contraste
parmi les prédictions de ces modèles alternatifs,
tel un scientifique dans un labo. Elle le fait
et essaye de l'expliquer, et d'éliminer ses propres modèles.
Ceci est le dernier cycle, et vous voyez qu'elle a plutôt
deviné à quoi elle ressemble, et une fois qu'elle sait quel est son modèle,
elle s'en sert pour déterminer son mode de déplacement.
Vous voyez ici des machines --
un modèle de déplacement.
Nous espérions qu'il acquerrait une sorte de démarche d'araignée,
mais au contraire, elle a créé cette manière plutôt boiteuse d'avancer.
En voyant cela, vous devez toutefois vous rappeler
que cette machine n'a pas pu tester physiquement comment avancer,
et n'avait pas modèle d'elle-même.
En gros, elle a deviné à quoi elle ressemble, et comment avancer,
et a ensuite essayé de le faire.
(Applaudissements)
Passons maintenant à une autre idée.
Que se passerait-il si nous avions un couple --
ce qui arrive quand vous avez un couple -- OK, OK, OK --
(Rires)
-- ils ne s'aiment pas.
Voici un autre robot.
Voici ce qui arrive quand les robots sont effectivement
récompensés pour avoir fait quelque chose.
Que se passe-t-il si vous ne les récompensez jamais, vous les laissez seuls?
Nous avons ces cubes, comme montrés sur le diagramme.
Le cube peut pivoter, tourner sur le côté,
nous lançons 1000 cubes dans une soupe --
en simulation du moins -- et nous ne les récompensons pas,
nous les laissons se retourner. Nous envoyons de l'énergie
et regardons les mutations qui peuvent arriver.
Au départ, rien ne se passe, ils se contentent de pivoter.
Mais peu après, vous pouvez voir ces choses bleues
sur la droite commencer à dominer.
Elles commencent à s'auto-répliquer. En l'absence de récompense,
la récompense intrinsèque est l'auto-réplication.
Nous en avons donc construit des comme cela,
qui sont un morceau d'un plus grand robot créé à partir de ces cubes,
voici en vue accélérée, le robot effectivement
en train de s'auto-répliquer.
Vous leur donnez plus de matériaux -- des cubes en l'occurrence --
et plus d'énergie, et cela crée un autre robot.
Bien sûr, c'est un robot très grossier,
mais nous travaillons à une version microscopique,
et nous espérons que les cubes seront comme une poudre à répandre.
Qu'apprenons-nous? Ces robots ne sont bien sûr
pas très utiles en eux-mêmes, mais ils pourraient nous apprendre
comment construire de meilleurs robots,
et peut-être comment les humains et les animaux créent leurs modèles et apprennent.
La chose la plus importante, est, je pense
que si nous devons sortir de cette idée
de concevoir des machines "à la main"
mais au contraire de les laisser évoluer et apprendre, comme des enfants,
peut-être nous y arriverons ainsi. Merci.
(Applaudissements)